you always kind of those are kind of
those far-off
dreams you think about like wonder if
you're ever going to play a game you
don't miss one and
you quickly say probably not
um but the fact that we were staying
there almost in the fourth quarter and
and we hadn't and again y'all weren't in
here i keep saying we because some of
the great catches down there are some
great catches that could very easily
fall incomplete and again the guy's
protecting the front so we we completed
25 in a row
career day for phillip rivers against
the arizona cardinals 25 consecutive
completions and he overall completed 28
of 29 passes both nfl single game
records and they were down 10 to nothing
early to the cardinals and the next
thing you know it's 45 to 10 the only
bad news
for the
chargers coming out of yesterday's game
melvin gordon reportedly diagnosed with
a grade 2 mcl sprain
and that usually means four weeks
so they're going to have to figure out
another way right down the stretch in
the regular season they get gordon back
maybe four of the last regular season
game or two and then he should be good
to go for the playoffs but uh the
chargers looking like the five seed
for now in the afc west although there's
still only one game separating them and
the chiefs what an opportunity blown
last week by the chargers when they lost
the broncos because right now they'd be
tied with the chiefs yeah after the
chiefs lost to the rams yeah i mean that
bad interception that rivers through to
von miller was a game-changing moment
for them but the charges are still
extremely dangerous and it does think
that melvin gordon goes out but you know
i think one of the things philip rivers
playing awesome this year i don't think
we talk about the weapons uh that they
have in the pass game enough they kind
of fly under the radar when you talk
about travis benjamin and keenan allen
and mike williams
that's a pretty good trio of receivers
let alone they have a few injuries there
right now but he was surgical in the
past game yesterday and yeah some of the
completions were easy but some were
unbelievable throws along the sidelines
down the field whatever it may be
the chargers are dangerous if they get
in the playoffs they are going to be
dangerous because of their scoring power
and joey joey as joey bosa gets more
comfortable he's back from that foot
injury and they they all la super bowl
wouldn't that be something if that
happens more pfd library after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports